it's great to have back on the program
today Douglas rushkoff who's a media
theorist professor at Cooney Queens
College and also author of the new book
survival of the richest Escape fantasies
of the tech billionaires which I
recently read and very much enjoyed
really great having you on today I
appreciate it it's good to see you so
the kind of jumping off point of the
book is that you are invited by some
billionaires uh to meet with them and
the meeting sort of goes a little bit
differently maybe than you anticipated
where they want advice not so much about
the technology of how to survive a
possible impending Mass catastrophic
event but more sort of like
socio-cultural and psychological
questions about like how do I prevent my
security force from turning against me
and sort of like taking all my food and
kind of this type of thing and one of
the big points you make in the book
which I find interesting is that these
billionaires are now looking to sort of
insulate themselves from the
consequences of the very system that
they used to enrich themselves in the
first place talk first just kind of
generally about this space that exists
this um uh uh sort of catastrophe and
disaster planning space and is it only
billionaires or is it also like the
hundred millionaires that are into this
so they give us a sense of the lay of
the land well it's interesting I mean
these guys in some ways these guys give
a bad name to Preppers everywhere you
know I I met a lot of Preppers since
doing this book and real preppers are
generally involved in strengthening
their communities they understand that
when you have Community resilience when
you've got local farms when you've
supported that you're gonna everyone's
gonna do better and these guys are not
are not Preppers in that sense they've
got such a go It Alone you know
self-sovereign individual you know
extreme libertarian understanding of
technology and money and identity that
they um wither without catastrophe they
want a private island they want a little
seastetting raft of their own they want
their own country their own government
you know their own social network their
own virtual womb you know that could
that can care for them so Adriana off I
started to look at their disaster prep
and catastrophe mindset more as a way of
justifying what they've been doing all
along you know there's there's I just
read a piece by Corey doctorow about
Epson printers and how Epson makes a
printer that bricks itself after it
prints out a certain number of pages it
just bricks itself and there's no really
good reason for it but except that they
want to sell Another Printer you know
and they justify it that oh well the
parts are going to be worn out by then
so we we spare the user the hassle of of
having a broken printer and we just lock
it you know but there's a guy right
there's I'm assuming it's a guy there's
a guy at Epson printer somewhere
thinking well yes this means I'm going
to have to send more kids into the mines
in Africa to get their Rare Earth medals
to make another printer and yes we're
gonna have to take that existing printer
and just Chuck it onto a landfill where
it's going to Leach toxic chemicals and
yes I am actually shortening the amount
of time between now and whatever
catastrophic climate event takes down
our civilization but the margin I'm
making selling these extra printers must
be making me enough money so I can get
my kids to a Rudolph Steiner school and
get a goat share and live in a private
Farm somewhere and be insulated from
this that I can stay that much ahead and
that's really what it's always been
these guys with an exit strategy
mentality needing to stay just one or
two steps ahead of the rest of the
investors so they can get out with their
carpet bag before the thing comes down
yeah and in the book you you refer to it
the mindset which I think incorporates
some some of these ideas that you're
talking about here you know one of the
things that I I've read is you know the
prep the sort of like normal Preppers
and then the the billionaires you're
talking about here and then like
everybody else whatever some of the
advice I've read kind of is summarized
as follows which is listen it makes
sense to plan for like a 10 to 14 day
cataclysm of some kind food water maybe
electricity with a generator you know
that that makes sense beyond that
it is so truly difficult to really set
yourself up to survive what we might
call long term in such an event that
it's not even really worth thinking
about that is increasingly something I'm
reading from a lot of these things but
when you say that though the implication
of that and that's what I the
implication of that is that means that
becoming a billionaire even without the
catastrophe is not the way to make
yourself the most safe and resilient
overall exactly exactly and so I guess
when is it that the billionaires think
that doesn't apply to them because of
the amount of money that they have
it's that the billionaires are aware
that they've spent the last 10 or 20
years of their lives
externalizing so much harm to the rest
of the world that they are afraid of it
coming back at them like Karma you know
most of these guys they are unconscious
Tech bro billionaires for the first 10
or 20 years and then they go down to
Burning Man and do some Ayahuasca and
realize oh my God the planet is crying
out to me she's dying you know they have
the same realization but then on the G5
back to San Jose they're like okay now
how do I protect myself from her like
the angry girlfriend that you haven't
called in a long time the planet you
know is coming from Revenge so the
question that I found really interesting
from the book which I already mentioned
is this idea of I I can do everything
right as a billionaire with every
resource available to me but if we
really get to a cataclysm my security
team might just turn against me and be
like let's kill this one guy and we can
keep all the food and we can survive you
talk in the book about well the way to
preempt that is probably to for the
years leading up to this event build uh
relationships and and cooperate and you
know make it so that they would see you
as one of them so to speak and not not
try to do that is that really
are they satisfied with that advice no
because they understand what that advice
is is really a trojan horse to try to
break down their mentality right I said
to them at that at that talk I said well
the way to make sure your head of
security doesn't kill you on the bunker
is pay for his daughters Bat Mitzvah
today right you know and I meant that in
some ways as a as a little Jewish joke
um but
they would have to do more than pay for
that one guy's daughters Bat Mitzvah and
while you're at it think about your
workers and while you're at that think
about the people living in the community
around you think about the the if you're
a Facebook executive think about the
tent Village right outside corporate
headquarters who are those people right
how do you look at them not as a city
problem but as a human problem you know
not something to bulldoze out of there
but something to actually address and
look at the actual impact of your
company on the world so if they started
thinking that way then there might not
be a catastrophe for them to hide from
at all right but they're attached to it
and that's partly I mean that's really
what the book looks at is how to
capitalism and the history of technology
and science and this kind of Dominator
mindset how do they all combine to
create this kind of colonial Vision
where all they can do is operate one
level above the rest of us you know they
kind of go from zero to one as T Peter
Thiel would say or go meta as Zuckerberg
would say right do derivatives of
derivatives as a finance guy would say
it's always one level up that's what
what Stuart brand said back in the the
70s you know we are as gods and we may
as well get good at it and the tech Pros
have taken that as as kind of a gospel
truth is your sense that these folks
you've talked to are more convinced that
such a world-changing event is coming
than other groups or is it simply that
they are more focused on using their
resources to prepare themselves for it
they're more convinced actually and
that's you know it's money after I I
wrote the first article on this book
I've gotten calls from lots and lots of
people in interesting places and one of
them is a giant hedge fund which is a um
uh a hedge fund that's positioned for
Global Calamity you know it's got a few
billion dollars in there and they showed
me their PowerPoint with charts from the
World Bank and the climatologists of
this and like okay in the next 10 years
these regions will become unlivable ten
years after that these ones will be the
only ones that are fertile soil this is
why we recommend buying land in Northern
Canada Siberia Greenland and this part
of Antarctica and it's like oh my God
and so
if they're being pitched those kinds of
things that we are not pitched and
they're so realistic
um and I suppose probable right because
people with real money do real studies
then then I think they are sort of more
aware of it than we are and I think they
understand that they're more causal to
it than we are we're just eating our
food and throwing out some plastic bags
occasionally and feeling guilty that we
know the recycling actually uses more
energy than it would cost to make a new
plastic bottle or whatever you know
where but these guys it's like Oh no
you're doing major you're doing things
at scale you know and you're doing
things at scale with a business model
that looks at all the damage as an
externality to your business and you're
aware that those externalities are
growing big enough to impact your life
and the lives of your kids
in the book you talk about technology
that some see maybe naively as maybe a
way out of some of the problems that
we've created for ourselves
um you talk a little bit about solar
panels and electric vehicles I think and
now I'm not sure if I'm if I'm if this
is from the book or from articles you've
written but in any case you've expressed
that you are less optimistic about some
of these Technologies uh being able to
kind of meet our energy needs in a truly
eco-friendly way I think there's a lot
of legitimacy to that the carbon
footprint of solar panels which degrade
over time and then what do we do with
them Rare Earth minerals required for
electric vehicle batteries what do you
do with the battery has reached the end
of its usable life Etc
just maybe I'm naive but isn't there
some degree to which those are problems
that can be significantly improved upon
by by engineering and the technology
simply improving from where it is today
that will change the scale and actually
make those Technologies genuinely game
changers maybe not the solution but
significantly significant improvements
oh
moving away from fossil fuels and
combustion is a necessary part
of the planet
Ary civilization moving toward
sustainability okay
saying over the next 10 years we're
going to convert every car to an
electric car and every house to a solar
panel house in order to get to zero
carbon emissions by 2030
is crazy because the amount of stuff
that we would dig up yeah in order to do
that energy with the amount of the
factories we'd have to open to build all
those cars and do all that stuff and
build all those batteries would destroy
us faster than anything else
so
that's my volunteer fire alarm the
volunteer fire department in our town is
old Tech that's what we're hearing now
they they extend that alarm and then
they check their pages to see
um where's the fire and they go it's
Community right right gotta love it you
gotta love it
um and they're volunteers
um it's gonna go one more time they do
it twice like if people woke up and
didn't hear how many beeps it was to
know if they're active but um
the these are all great but the amount
of energy we're using now is
you know a great uh energy theorist
named uh Nate Nate hoggins talks about
this it's like a pulse of energy we're
not using energy in like a
we're using like explosions of energy in
order to power these cities the the the
you know hundreds of thousands of years
of stored energy that gets burnt in like
two days is is you know a massive and
unsustainable so uh we we also need to
reduce the amount of energy we use you
know and that's not
shockingly hard you know we built the
American landscape around the needs of
the automobile industry where people
have to drive to get to work and all so
there are many many ways to reduce our
energy footprint that of our of our
corporations and that of our us as
individuals and it it involves a lot of
economic rejiggering too if you've got
an oil industry that's depending on
resource depletion and you've got all
these pensioners who are dependent on
the oil industry or an S P 500 or a GDP
that's depending on the growth of
companies that are destroying us you
kind of do have to do more than the
physical re-engineering of energy
production but the the code engineering
of our economy you know and that's where
it gets scary Yeah you mentioned GDP so
I again I don't remember exactly where
you wrote this but I've read something
you wrote about you know a criticism of
401ks and uh the sort of stock market as
a pyramid scheme I think was the analogy
that that you used I'm there's this
interview I remember at some point Noam
Chomsky gave where he was sort of like
confronted and I used that in in scare
quotes he was confronted about the fact
that despite all of his criticisms of
all these different types of companies
um his like retirement accounts are
invested in the same you know kind of
index funds that that everybody uses and
his response was something like well
yeah I mean what you want me to keep the
money under my mattress or some
something along those lines are you
despite your view on the impossibility
of indefinite growth based on GDP growth
on a planet with limited resources your
criticism of 401k Etc are you invested
in the same stuff
some yeah I mean that was the main thing
I'm in a group called Equitable
Enterprise at Institute for the future
in in uh they're like in Palo Alto and
they were talking about all these new
models and all this and that's what I
brought up in the first meeting I said
what if we all took 50 of our retirement
savings and invested them locally or in
land trusts or in other things and
people are like
well I won't really we've got to make
structural change that one and I think
yeah I know you got to make structural
change and all that but what if we by
example did it and then encouraged
everybody else to take just half of
their retirement savings let's say we
could only they kept saying it was just
such a small measure saying what if we
could only move a couple of trillion
dollars into local economics you know
what would that do it would be massive a
massive amount of change so yeah one of
the main things I'm looking at is how do
we and I hate using words like scale but
how do we make it really easy for people
instead of selecting s p Index Fund to
select local index billion small
businesses fund how do we invest in land
trusts you know you're going to get
different kinds of returns you're going
to end up getting dividend returns and
earnings returns rather than the capital
gains of selling some massively thing
you're not going to get 100 x Returns on
restoring local businesses at least not
for that long you know you might have
been beginning as we recover a local
economy
but you know that's what I'm looking at
so I'm looking at lots of um I mean I'm
invested in land trusts and uh there's
some local farming uh things you know
funds where you you you lend money to
Farmers at a low interest rate and get
it back so you know I'm I'm looking at
you know three and four percent returns
as a good thing rather than a bad thing
you know and
just because I earned money doesn't mean
I'm allowed to have my money be worth
more later you know that doesn't I can
I'll save up money for my retirement but
I also then you know in addition to
wanting to get to you know just hold my
money certainly at the rate of inflation
um I want to create a community that
will support me when I'm older so I'm
not entirely dependent on my cash right
to take care of me when I'm old and that
means engendering a different kind of
society and you walk around Europe you
see old people they're living in the
house with their kids they're they're
part of the social fabric they're out
there on the stoop at night playing with
the babies and taking care of the little
ones so the husband and wife can go down
to the movies and the teenagers can make
out over there and these guys it's like
a a an interdependent Society you know
and that's what a social economy is this
is what Marx was talking about not some
big top-down central government
organization he was like no no economics
is social it's people doing things for
one another and maybe it's not on The
Ledger maybe there's not a doubt or a
blockchain keeping track of whether
Grandma took care of the kids for two
hours so now someone's going to give her
a bath you know you don't need to put
that on the blockchain
last thing just because you mentioned it
is the entire crypto thing over
no the entire crypto thing is not over
it
it may have gone through
it may have gone through the.com bust
the equivalent of 1999 2000 and then
we'll see you know there was there were
two possibilities after the.com bust we
kind of got blogger and Friendster and
Napster and some interesting things but
then we also got Myspace and Facebook
and Instagram and the ucky ones won
right rather than the kind of pro-social
creative ones I'd be interested to see
if the the young crypto community that
I'm still aware of the the kids who are
making nfts for good reasons not to
become millionaires but to support their
art and the kids who are building Dows
you know Dows that help other people
make Dows in order to figure out the
governance structure of their
organization or their Community if those
people went out then
um crypto could come back in a positive
way if crypto comes back as you know
what it was before which is a way for
[ __ ] to speculate on you know
abstract assets then you know All Is
Lost the latest book is uh survival of
the richest Escape fantasies of the tech
billionaires we've been speaking with
the book's author media theorist and
Professor Douglas rushkoff always great
having you on really appreciate it oh I
appreciate what you do